what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can help decide what direction
the content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable
future okay so continuing our whole
thing about superior Spider-Man uh this
is when we actually delve into um you
know really Spider-Man 2099 now here's
going to be the kicker to the to to this
whole thing here's going to be the
craziness is like the middle of this
story there's going to be like a
singular moment that takes place in the
story and it's going to be one panel and
then another panel between those two
panels the entirety of spiderverse takes
place and it's kind of crazy the way
that Dan slot did it uh but it was still
really really cool and and we'll we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it but
what we do here is we actually pick up
with NOA New York uh which is I'm sorry
NOA York which is basically New York in
the year 2099 um but what I want to do
here is I want to have a little bit of a
discussion about Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 2099 now this version of 2099
that we're seeing here is not the
traditional Spider-Man 2099 Universe
instead that's actually referred to as
Earth 928 and remember whenever it comes
to Futures in Marvel Comics just say you
know 20 years from now or 100 years from
now or something like that those are
usually always considered to be like you
know alternate realities they're usually
always considered to be like dystopian
futures or something like that or
sometimes they enlightened Futures but
because of the fact that that future is
not guaranteed Marvel just kind of
chalks it up to an alternate reality now
aspects of that future may be guaranteed
but the future in and of itself in terms
of how we see it is not guaranteed to
happen with 2099 traditionally that is
to say the you know Spider-Man 2099 1992
Peter David run what it basically
happened is that there was a massive
civil war between humans and mutants and
eventually it led to the point where the
Earth uh basically experienced this
systemic breakdown of social classes in
the sense you basically just had the
super rich and then everybody else and
so what it did is it basically created a
very corporatized environment where
there was non-stop advertising
everything was corporate it was 100% if
you weren't Rich you were basically poor
and you were living your life as best
you could um the idea here was that at
the time because of the fact that that
Heroes like Spider-Man were really kind
of considered to be archaic they were
reminiscent of days gone by Miguel
O'Hara had actually become part of a
group called alchemax and the idea was
that Miguel O'Hara himself looked to the
idea of Spider-Man and then eventually
took up the mantle now this coincided
with like a new generation of
superheroes who basically began rising
up but adopted the mantle of previous
people whether they were villains or
anti-heroes and so you had like Punisher
2099 and you had you know all these
different characters that we knew and
loved but as 2099 counterparts now truth
be told I thought about going back and
covering Spider-Man 2099 I thought about
going back and and covering all that
stuff I mean right now we can't just
because we have so much to do like we
have all this Spider-Man then
spider-verse and then you know all new
all different Amazing Spider-Man and
then we transition over to Thor then we
transition over to the entire Marvel
cosmology and the origin of Thanos and
the remastering of Infinity Gauntlet and
the infinity war and infinity Crusade
and a million things that we're going to
do uh really going in for for the next
little while but I may try to find a
place to squeeze in uh Spider-Man 299
because Miguel is a really really cool
character I really love what he brings
to the superhero landscape but the fact
remains here that that we really just
kind of join him in the aftermath of the
Age of Ultron and that's where the
future that we're seeing right now
that's where that hails from one of the
big questions a lot of people had is
like how did galatis from like the main
Marvel Universe cross over into the
Ultimate Universe you know what was
going on with the Ultimate Universe
during the collapse of the Multiverse
all that kind of stuff so now to kind of
Sidetrack here for a second away from
this this Spider-Man story and bear with
me here cuz we're going to we're going
to jump back into it when Marvel was
basically setting the stage for the
collapse of the Multiverse and basically
going into Hickman's whole Avengers and
New Avengers and all that kind of stuff
they had this great big huge Ser like a
lot of these series of events that were
designed for the purpose of basically
wrapping things up or at the very least
allowing Marvel to segue into stories
that would you know basically lead up to
the collapse of the Multiverse original
sin was one of the most notable in the
sense that original sin showed that Nick
Fury had killed the Watcher but in terms
of Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers
it showed that Captain America was
previously part of the Illuminati and
then basically was ousted because he
didn't agree with the idea of destroying
worlds that were going to crash into the
main Marvel Universe and Destroy them
both and so because of that the
Illuminati kicked him out and wiped his
memory and so it created all these
really cool stories and things like that
and we'll we'll cross that bridge when
we go through our whole following Thanos
throughout the history of Marvel's
cosmology all of his stories and
everything going into the remastering of
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers but
the fact remains here that in terms of
the age of ultra story uh what that did
is it basically had Wolverine travel
back in time uh and then kill Hank Pim
only to travel back in time a second
time and stop himself from killing Hank
pimp and so because of the fact that the
story was in and of itself crazy in
terms of time travel what Brian Michael
Bendis and Marvel did is they said
there's been too many instances on too
many occasions in Marvel Comics when
people have traveled back in time to try
to fix things the time is not some
linear construct time is effectively a
living organism and so by virtue of
Wolverine going back in time so many
times he basically broke time itself
that's a lot of times that we throwing
out there he essentially broke time
itself and so what it did is it sent
ripples it sent shock waves throughout
the entirety of the Marvel Multiverse
which set in motion a lot of things and
really helped to contribute to the
collapse of the Multiverse but in terms
of this uh this you know getting back
into the Spider-Man in terms of this
future as we see it right now we don't
know exactly what it was that happened
all we know is that the conclusion of
Age of Ultron had Ripple effects
throughout the entire Multiverse and it
somehow affected this particular
Universe now the idea here seems to be
that again you know kind of picking up
with Miguel it's really just uh just you
know Dan slot showing us here's what
Spider-Man is about here's what
Spider-Man you know Spider-Man 2099 does
he's a futuristic version of Spider-Man
his suits a little more durable it's got
special little goodies that separate him
and and that's really the way it goes in
the realm of the Spider-Man landscape
whether it's Miles Morales and the
Ultimate Universe whether it is you know
Peter Parker with the iron spider armor
whether it's Miguel O'Hara whether it's
Kane you know Bill or I'm sorry um I
almost said Bill O'Reilly whether it's
Ben Riley whatever the case may be it's
basically just all these different
versions of Spider-Man have something
that make them different something that
make them a little unique their suits or
their powers or so on and so forth and
so because of this what ends up
happening here is of course Miguel is
basically just kind of saving the day
but the reason why is because of the
fact that again this Age of Ultron
Ripple event has basically caused a
massive catastrophe in the city in terms
of the time stream being all screwed up
now a lot of this is stemming from
alchemax itself alchemax being the mega
corporation that basically runs the show
it's almost like a futuristic version of
you know roxson oil or something like
that the main Marvel Universe where
roxon is extremely corrupt organization
that has its hands in all different
kinds of politics and behind the scenes
some very shady things assassinations of
public officials different things like
that alchemax is very much like that in
the future but it's one of these things
where it kind of represents the
corrupted nature of you know
corporations and capitalism and so on
and so forth there's a lot of political
themes that went into the original
Spider-Man 2099 line of stories but the
fact remains here that within the realm
of alchemax uh Tyler stone is really
kind of the guy running the whole
situation but Tyler stone is the son of
Tiberia Stone and in fact Mel O'Hara
himself is the son of Tyler Stone and so
because of this Miguel O'Hara and his
father are really in a kind of a battle
like this eternal battle of Good and
Evil so to speak in the sense that they
fight each other but what makes the
situation a little more Dynamic is it
would be like if Bruce Wayne became
Batman and Thomas Wayne his father
became the Joker like they're just kind
of at odds against one another and they
will be until the end of time the issue
here is that because of the actions of
of wolf rain during Age of Ultron
something in the past was screwed up
something in the past went wrong and so
the idea is that Tyler stes effectively
disappearing from the time stream now
what's really cool about this is the way
that Dan slot does it under normal
circumstances when we think of the
grandfather Paradox which is to say if
you went back in time and you met your
grandfather as a child and accidentally
killed him then you would cease to exist
traditionally we just have you just kind
of break down on on you know on the
atomic level you simply just phase out
of existence because you couldn't exist
in the first place if your grandfather
was killed but the reason why it's
called a grandfather Paradox is if your
grandfather died before you could be
born then how could you have gone back
in time in the first place so again it
creates all kinds of weird situations
but the way Dan slot does it here is it
basically gives us a chance it basically
gives him a uh gives him time to correct
the problem in the sense that in instead
of Tyler Stone just Vanishing out of
thin air Tyler Stone's basically just
sort of Disappearing and so what it
tells us is that in the past there's a
sequence of events there's you know the
first event then the second event then
the third event and we're probably on
the second at the moment which means
that the the closer these events get to
the point where you know tiberious Stone
the the father of Tyler Stone vanishes
then the closer we get to Tyler Stone
disappearing in his entire and so
because of this Miguel's basically
tasked with the idea of saving the
father of Tyler Stone now the reason why
this is interesting is because on the
surface Miguel's like look you're my
mortal enemy like there's no reason for
me to save you if you die the world will
be a better place well the issue with
this is then we start invoking
hypothetical scenarios you know
hypothetical possibilities the world
exists as it does now in you know the
2099 Universe because a series of events
took place that led it to where it is
whether or not it's a huge event whether
or not it's a small event Tyler Stone
was born if Tyler Stone was never born
what would the world look like if
alchemax never never came to power it
might be better it could be worse and so
because of this because of the fact that
there's no telling what the future may
be May hold we end up actually finding
out that uh that Miguel traveling into
the past is guaranteed and the reason
why is because they show an image of him
in the past and so this basically means
that he's going to jump back into the
year 2013 and try to figure out what
happened that set all these events in
Motion in the first place now what we
end up doing is we actually jump back to
you know again Peter Parker superior
Spider-Man and it's really kind of a
cool moment here in the since he's
playing baseball and he smashes the ball
out of the
park and that's kind of what we would
expect right like like Peter Parker
playing baseball like I'd never play
baseball against Peter Parker like I
don't care how fast you can throw the
ball he's going to smash it and then
everybody's you know everybody's fun is
going to be ruined and so because of
that because we don't like people
ruining other people's fun I would not
play against Peter Parker but the cool
thing here is that this entire situation
is being monitored by tiberious Stone so
again we're back here in the present
with the father of Tyler Stone uh
Tiberius himself and so so because of
this what this really means is that
tiberious is basically engineering the
fall of uh you know really of of horizon
Labs now remember Horizon Labs is the
organization that's basically founded by
Max Modell it's a giant think tank it's
designed to basically grab some of the
Bright Young members of society and have
them create inventions and different
things like that that will make Society
better it's very similar to like
Hickman's Future Foundation under Reed
Richards and that's part for the course
right I mean in Marvel Comics ESP you
know even in DC Comics you don't have
like one organization that represents
one thing like you don't have like one
government sanctioned superhero team you
don't have one you know think tank all
different kinds of people have different
kinds of think tanks Reed Richards has a
future foundation which is some of the
world's smartest kids that he's allowed
in there Max Modell has Horizon Labs
we'll see Parker Industries begin to
take form over the course of this story
you see a lot of different organizations
and groups that serve the same purpose
you know but they're basically just led
by different people now it doesn't mean
they're at ODS it's not like Max Modell
is like I hate readed Richards and this
Future Foundation yeah I'm going to get
those evil kids I mean it's nothing like
that you know there's nothing is is as
as silly and Sinister as that but it
just serves the purpose of kind of
reminding us there's a much bigger world
in in the realm of Corporations and
companies and so on and so forth but the
reason why uh why tiberious stone is so
significant here is because of the fact
that what tiberious stone has been doing
or at least what he's done is he's
basically set the stage for Horizon labs
to essentially go under for Max Modell
himself to be arrested uh due to the
fact that the the different experiments
that he's been working on have basically
come into into light as being illegal in
the sense that he's tampering with time
uh since that he basically tried to make
or at least one of the people there
tried to make a knockoff of vibranium
and ultimately screwed it up created
rivium instead different things like
that now Max Modell wasn't the one who
invented these things but it's a classic
example that if you're at work and you
screw up if somebody higher than your
boss sees it it makes your boss look bad
because your boss is in charge of you
and so because of that Max Modell is
basically the one taking the fall here
because he's the one who's in charge of
horizon laps he's responsible for all
the different experiments that his
employees are working on at the moment
now at this point uh we're basically
kind of reminded by Dan slot that Goblin
nation is still going on which is to say
Norman Osborne is still making his own
Green Goblin Army this isn't wildly
significant here it's just kind of a
little small reminder but it's Dan slot
basically saying you know keep in the
back of your head guys Norman Osborne
the Green Goblin basically found a way
to hack into a superior Spider-Man's
little spider bots in order to keep all
the Goblins in New York hidden away from
those Bots they won't know the Goblins
are there they won't detect them and
they won't report back and so because of
that it's basically Dan slot reminding
us that that superior Spider-Man is
completely unaware of the fact that
Green Goblin is building an army for
himself within the city of New York now
at this point we transition over to Alim
and Alim is basically just the the
predecessor to Alx but the idea here is
that alchem is basically taken over
Horizon Labs or is it really kind of
initiating a uh you know a hostile
takeover now this is basically short for
Alan chimical but because of the fact
that the head of horizon Live's Max
Modell is being taken away essentially
what happened here is is again by nature
of it being a hostile takeover Allan
kimal has bought controlling stake in in
Horizon labs and that's why it's
considered to be a hostile takeover uh
because B basically when you have
publicly traded companies the people who
have a majority sh a majority hold in
the company have a lot more Authority
than those who don't with uh with alen
chimical holding the majority shares of
horizon labs this now means that Alan
chemical owns Horizon labs and so they
can dissolve the company they can absorb
the company they can do any number of
things that they want now of course
Superior Spider-Man's very much aware
that tiberious stone seems to have a
hand in this as is most everybody else
just because of the fact that tiberious
is on with Alan chimical and it's like
hey look guys we'll keep you around you
know if we're interested if we choose to
but it's really superior Spider-Man kind
of chasing them down with the intention
of tracking these guys down now at this
point we actually pick up with Grady
remember Gray's one of the members of of
horizon labs and Grady basically came to
the idea that in his mind tiberious
Stone had set in motion these events
which is to say he believes the
tiberious stone had sabotaged these
different experiments which is the
reason why they had gone arai and it's
the reason for why Maxim Modell is being
arrested in the first place so the
intention of Grady is to travel back in
time and to Simply witness what it is
that uh that tiberious stone is doing
now this is the inherent difference
between what it is that Dan slot's doing
in this story and what we would see in
traditional time travel stories in
traditional stories where time travel is
invoked time travel in and of itself is
just a way out it's a way for a rider to
get themselves out of a hole they write
this incredibly amazing story and a
super super good but then they don't
know how to end it well then suddenly
Here Comes doctor strange and Doctor
Strange whisks them away to the Future
and then everything's okay it's one of
those things that fans absolutely hate
because it's a lazy way to end a story
what Dan lot does here is he doesn't use
time to end a story he uses time travel
to further a story and that's where fans
don't really have any problem with it
you know fans are like hey look if it's
a means to an end which is to say it's a
tool to be used in order to give us an
organic ending to a story then that's
fine then that works and so what ends up
happening here is uh is Grady basically
just kind of jumps back and starts
looking through different points now
before Grady can actually enter this
device Miguel O'Hara suddenly jumps
through and again this really kind of
feeds into the idea of Miguel being here
in the sense that you know the guys at
alchemax in year in the year 2099 sent
him through through this portal because
it was a two-way street it was going to
be opened up it was basically Grady
opening the door and then they knew at
least at Alx they knew this door would
be open at this particular time and it
would allow Miguel to jump through and
so because of this Miguel is basically a
man on a mission his idea is trying to
figure out what it is that's taking
place that's leading to the death of
Tyler Stone in the year 2099 why it is
that Tyler stone is disappearing from
existence and so with superior
Spider-Man catching up to uh to to
tiberious Stone and the intention of
killing him uh the funny thing here is
that tiberious is like well you know you
can't harm me I mean you know you're
Spider-Man you don't kill people I'm
following within the confines of the law
what I'm doing is legal yeah it's really
crummy and yeah it's really shady but
you can't hurt me right and this really
kind of goes back to the discussion that
we had about Injustice you know Free
Will gives people the the freedom to do
anything they want to but it also gives
them the freedom to deal with the
consequences the consequences may not be
legal the consequences may just be that
you piss somebody off really bad and
they're going to kill you that's the
consequence of the things that you said
and the things that you did that's
what's going on on here with tiberious
he basically pissed off superior
Spider-Man by screwing him over and
screwing over the entirety of horizon
Labs now the other half of this is this
Dan slot furthering this idea that Dr
Octopus in the body of Peter Parker is
becoming a good guy because under normal
circumstances we wouldn't have seen Dr
Octopus do this Dr Octopus would have
been like well I mean you know I'll look
at the look at the entire situation get
a lay of the land and if it's if it
works in my benefit I'll let it happen
if it doesn't then I'll stop it but then
I'll try to find some way to make sure
that I come out on top here superior
Spider-Man is being altruistic in this
situation what tiberious stone is doing
is wrong Horizon Labs is a great
organization Max Modell is a legit guy
superior Spider-Man is basically going
to try to kill tiberious Stone because
he's a dick he doesn't deserve to live
and Horizon Labs is going to continue on
exonerated of the crimes that has been
falsely accused of so that's kind of the
cool thing here is this this is
altruistic Spider-Man now the funny
thing about this too is that dook has
never met Spider-Man 2099 he doesn't
know who Miguel O'Hara is and this is
Dan slot kind of hearkening back to to
the death quote unquote of Peter Parker
when superior Spider-Man basically
purged all of Peter Parker's legitimate
memories from his mind the issue here is
that when Miguel O'Hara First shows up
Peter Parker's met Miguel before they
they've been a team they've teamed up on
a multitude of occasions Miguel knows
who Spider-Man is he knows Spider-Man is
Peter Parker but Dr Octopus doesn't know
this and so in his mind this is just a
guy who looks like Spider-Man he doesn't
know where he's from he doesn't know
what he's about and so Miguel kind of
initially greets him as a friend
superior Spider-Man greets him as an
enemy and so what this does is lead to a
fight between the two now in terms of
Miguel he's basically trying to solve
this problem he's trying to figure out
what's going on and so in a lot of ways
what he's doing here is he's looking at
Superior looking at Spider-Man and
saying I don't know what happened to you
I don't know what's been done to you but
you've become more extreme and if I have
to put you down in order to preserve the
future that's exactly what I'll do now
at this point we also have Tyler Stone
in the future communicating with you
know Miguel O'Hara and this is when
Tyler basically says hey look you know
that Spider-Man referenced that guy as
tiberious Stone that's my father and and
so if he dies I will cease to exist
that's the issue here tiberious Stone
somewhere along the line was killed and
so because of the fact that he was
killed my entire existence is coming to
an end as will yours and so again this
is Dan slot kind of meddling around with
time a little bit kind of messing with
time itself but again it still kind of
works at this point miguelo Hera's role
is solidified we now know exactly what
it is that he's doing here his job is to
preserve the life of tiberious stone the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that there is a segment and
there there there will be a section
coming up when Miguel doesn't know if he
should he's like maybe I should just
sacrifice my life and make the future
better you know I'll let tiberious Stone
die or I'll kill him myself Tyler Stone
will cease to exist and then I will
cease to exist but at the end of the day
it'll all still work out because the
future will be a better place or at
least I hope it will be and so in the
midst of all this we pick up with with
Grady and again Grady jumping through
here you know kind of going back in time
it's not wildly significant all it
really does is just confirm the fact
that tiberious stone was messing around
and sabotaging these different
experiments that had gone wrong at at
Horizon lives so we don't really need to
go super in-depth into that I mean
that's really the extent of what we
would be what we would be discussing
anyway I think kind of the main focus
here should be on Miguel and inor
Spider-Man and so the conflict the
battle between the two of them is
actually really interesting is actually
really cool in the sense that they're
both relatively evenly matched but
Spider-Man 299 has Tech at his disposal
and that's one of the differences here
but that's also something that Dan
slot's kind of hearkening on because of
the fact that Dr Octopus took over the
body of Peter Parker in Miguel O'Hara's
future superior Spider-Man is a part of
the Spider-Man Mythos it'll be chocked
up to the idea that Spider-Man became
really really extreme for a little while
but the different tools that dook used
in terms of his time as Spider-Man his
enhancements to the suit all of that
falls into the different studies that
Miguel O'Hara has done on Spider-Man and
so whether Miguel O'Hara knows it or not
his role as Spider-Man 2099 is
influenced by the things that Doc O has
done as superior Spider-Man and so again
it's really kind of interesting to to
sort of see them meet and to see how one
influences the other but with tiberious
stone having the ability to basically
disrupt Spider-Man's spider sense of
course what this does is it allows
Miguel O'Hara to take off with tiberious
stone and of course you know following
this it's basically superior Spider-Man
trying to track him down and trying to
figure out what's going on now this is
the segment when Miguel begins to
question whether or not he's doing the
right thing he sits down and he
basically says look you know if I let
tiberious Stone die then that means that
he'll never have Tyler Stone which means
Tyler Stone will never have me I'll
cease to exist but alchemax will never
become what it is tiberious Stone will
not be able ble to lay the groundwork
for alemx Tyler Stone will never be able
to build on that groundwork and the
world will not be as crappy as it is but
the funny thing about this is that
Miguel o ha is not taking into account
the realm of possibilities you know in a
in a free market system if Microsoft
fails somebody will take their place if
Apple fails somebody will take their
place God willing Ubisoft fails somebody
will take their place because of this
what this means is that you know Miguel
O'Hara could very well be trading one
devil for another and in this situation
the devil you know is better than the
devil you don't and so because of this
he could be making a much worse future
and that's something that he
contemplates he says look I don't know
what the future would be like if I cease
to exist if Alx cease to exist who knows
how the future could turn out I mean who
knows if alchemax could basically restr
be restructured 100 years from now and
it leads Earth into this utopian era and
if I if I kill tiberious stone that
utopian era never comes into existence
because people never see alchemax they
never come to the conclusion we need
something better than that we can have a
better Society for ourselves he's like I
can make things worse in the long run
and so because of that he ultimately
says look I have to let him live and so
with this in mind Tiberia Stone kind of
has you know upper hand he has the upper
hand here because of the fact that he
jumps off the building he's like I
guarantee you're going to save me and so
he jumps off the building Spider-Man 299
saves his life and so it's almost
guaranteed that his future is set in
stone and so because of this with this
story intending to lead into spiderverse
and with the really The Superior
Spider-Man run designed to sort of wrap
things up and bring things winding down
uh what isend up happening here is
superior Spider-Man eventually catches
up with uh with with Miguel O'Hara now
the funny thing here this is actually
kind of a hilarious moment uh Miguel
realizing what it is that's going on
realizing that all of reality is
basically at the threat of Destruction
simply because of the fact that one of
the experiments Tiberia Sona messed with
was an experiment dealing with time
which in turn would basically lead to
the destruction of all thing because all
the energy being emitted by this time
travel device can't be contained Miguel
O'Hara shows up on the scene with
tiberious stone and says look guys
everything's beginning to go arai
everything's beginning to go insane the
only way for us to fix this is to follow
my lead and the reason why is because
Miguel O'Hare is like look I come from a
future where this happened and I know
that what you guys are going to try to
do is fail but I know the way to fix
this problem and so the issue here is
that while he's on the vers once he once
he says look you know all we have to do
is this thing superior Spider-Man shows
up out of nowhere and knocks him out and
it's a funny moment because then
everybody's just like dude what did you
do we're like we're like 15 minutes away
from the destruction of the world and
the universe itself why did you knock
out the one guy who could save us now
the reason why I say this leads into
spiderverse is because of the fact that
with Miguel O'Hara knocked out it now
Falls onto superior Spider-Man to take
to take the lead here the issue is that
again with him wiping the memories of
Peter Parker he doesn't know how to
solve this problem and the reason why is
because of the fact that when the
original vibranium experiment by SNY
Joffrey went aai and Peter Parker as his
normal self basically began manipulating
energy in order to contain the energy
that was led off contain the explosion
and the destruction of horizon Labs uh
superior Spider-Man purged that memory
and so he doesn't know what Peter Parker
did in order to keep that a massive
amount of energy from totally collapsing
in on itself and that's what this is
this is basically a much larger version
of the energy L off by sa Joffrey's
attempts to make vibrin and remember we
had talked about how you know at least
during that story we had talked about
how Dr Doom invading wakanda uh
basically taking vibranium had led to
Black Panther rendering all vibranium
across the world inert which in turn led
to SNY Joffrey trying to make artificial
vibranium it had all sort of led up to
this moment when Peter Parker's
intelligence was being demonstrated now
superior Spider-Man doesn't doesn't know
what to do and so he's basically on the
verge of being seen as a complete and
total fraud he's on the verge of being
seen in a guy as a guy who doesn't know
what he's doing who's basically making
things up along the way and so because
of this with this massive time device on
the verge of completely and totally you
know obliterating everything what
happens is superior Spider-Man tells
everybody to leave he starts meddling
with the device trying to find a way to
fix it and then the entirety of horizon
Labs just vanishes up in thin air
totally disappears now because of the
fact that tiberious stone was saved by
Miguel O'Hara what this means is that
tiberious stone is now safe I guess it
means that that Tyler Stone in the
future is is still alive and the future
is guaranteed now this was the moment
that Tyler Stone was talking about in
this moment right now things went a
different way we don't know exactly what
way things had normally gone in but what
seems to have been the case is that in
this scenario a superior Spider-Man at
some point along the line did not tell
them to leave and so the result was that
they were all basically yanked through
the time stream and tiberious stone was
presumably killed somewhere you know
during that time frame and it led to the
destruction of everything or it led to
the death of Tyler stone or the presumed
you know death of Tyler Stone which
would have led to this led to the death
of Miguel O'Hara hence the entire
situation why Miguel is here in the
first place but in this moment when
superior Spider-Man basically vanishes
and then the moment that he reappears on
the street the entirety of spiderverse
took place that being said we are going
to discuss the whole spiderverse event
the issue here is that with the whole
spiderverse event it's not an easy thing
to sort out there's actually a lot of
leadup in terms of like Moran and in
terms of Ezekiel and the other storyline
and you know the clone saga and all
different kinds of kinds of things
there's there's all kinds of stuff that
goes on there uh but the fact remains
here that again Dan lot sort of wrapping
things up bringing things to a close and
one of the things that he wraps up
pretty fast is the idea of Mary Jane
Watson Mary Jane Watson had been trying
to get a hold of superior Spider-Man
this entire time and he was basically
getting annoyed with her saying look she
needs to move on like she needs to get
her life together she needs to move on
get another guy she's hung up on me it's
it's a problem well of course when she
when he finally calls her back she
basically says look I've been hung up on
you it's time for me to move on I have
no romantic interest in you
anymore and so it's basically Dan slot
saying hey look these two guys are never
going to get together these two guys are
never going to to be anything
significant to one another now from this
point going forward what this does is it
basically picks up with the aftermath of
spiderverse and it picks up with
superior Spider-Man ramping things up
extremely fast to basically make a
better life for Peter Parker and that's
kind of the funny thing here at the same
time it's also him trying to make sure
that he stays superior Spider-Man and
we'll we'll cross that bridge once we
get to it with the spiderverse line of
stories but uh from this point what
we're going to do is we're actually
going to stop superior Spider-Man and
we're going to jump back and we're going
to start covering the superior uh I
guess the spiderverse stuff so we're
going to jump back to some of the older
stories of Amazing Spider-Man and then
pick up into uh into spiderverse
hopefully that way we have everything
covered in order to to to make it all
make sense and then once spiderverse is
done we'll jump back here to Superior
Spider-Man is the best way I know how to
do it in order to make sure that we fall
into the chronology of The Amazing
Spider-Man because that's what all this
is I mean this is all designed for the
purpose so that when the Spider-Man
movie comes out and people are searching
for Spider-Man content everywhere they
can pick up with these videos and
chronologically go through everything
about the Spider-Man mythology and learn
everything there is to learn in terms of
dance slots run with big time going
forward going into all new all different
Marvel but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the robore if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you guys later
[Music]
peace
turn